un sistema colapsado debido a la
cantidad de solicitudes de asilo de
nicaragüenses en costa rica por lo que
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
ayuda con personal el sistema de refugio
de costa rica- ha tenido dificultades
para hacer frente a ese incremento tan
importante de solicitudes de refugio que
ha habido desde 2018 el acnur ha apoyado
al gobierno de costa rica mediante la
contratación de 50 personas en la unidad
de refugio que ayudan a procesar estos
casos y hacer frente al rezago ahora de
tantos años este por la acumulación de
casos las peticiones suman unas 200.000
una cifra que representa el 4 por ciento
de la población costarricense y son más
de los que hubo en la década de los 80
durante el éxodo ocasionado por las
guerras civiles en la región unas 50.000
personas están esperando cita para hacer
una solicitud formal costa rica con 5
millones de habitantes fue el segundo
país después de eeuu en recibir el mayor
número de aplicaciones de asilo la cifra
se ha incrementado desde 2021 cuando el
presidente nicaragüense daniel ortega
arremetió contra la oposición y
encarceló parte de ella costa rica sigue
siendo la primera opción para los
nicaragüenses que emigran con mayor
motivo fue el por beneficio de trabajo
trabajito que uno puede lograr a tener
allá
es complicado para el mantenimiento de
la familia
y gracias a dios aquí en costa rica nos
dan el apoyo de
trabajar y ayudar un poco más a la
familia
muchos de ellos al ver la demora en sus
peticiones ponen sus ojos hacia eeuu y
méxico donde esperan lejos de casa tener
un futuro